how to give your containers proof that
you built them or in fancier terms build
provenance
so this Google Cloud build configuration
is going to build us a container image
and it does it in two steps we can see
the first one is uh to build the image
and the second is to push it to artifact
registry now if we make one small change
to this configuration replacing the push
step with this images stance that you
see above
Google Cloud bill will not only push
this container image to artifact
registry but it'll also create what is
called an attestation and all of this
that you're looking at here this is an
attestation it's essentially a unique
document with information about how our
container image was built what it was
built from where it was built when Etc
and when it comes to deployment time to
platforms like gke and Cloud run you can
make sure that these attestations are
present for the images that they're
actually running to make sure you're
running what you built want to learn
more check out the comments